في نهاية هذا الأسبوع ، اتخذنا نهجًا
شاملاً ، تستعد الوكالات الصحية في جميع أنحاء البلاد
لارتفاع حالات الإصابة بفيروس كورونا حيث
يحث المسؤولون الناس على اتخاذ
الاحتياطات اللازمة للحفاظ على أنفسهم
والآخرين بصحة جيدة إذا شعرت بالمرض والبقاء في
المنزل إذا كنت ''  بدأت تشعر بالمرض ،
لا تذهب إلى العمل ، لا تذهب إلى المدرسة ، تراقب
فرقة عمل اتحادية بقيادة نائب الرئيس
مايك بنس التطورات التي تم
إعدادها لنشر المساعدة الفيدرالية في
المجتمعات المتضررة ، فأنا على ثقة
أكثر من أي وقت مضى بأننا نجلب
نهج الحكومة بأكملها ،
وجه الرئيس
الموارد الكاملة للحكومة الفيدرالية الآن
يعمل أعضاء الكونجرس
لتأمين تلك الموارد التي طلبتها 8.5
مليار دولار و 1.5 مليار لمركز السيطرة على الأمراض
لمواصلة الاستجابة السريعة 3 مليارات
للصحة العامة 2 مليار  لتعويض
الولاية والمحليات وأخيراً
مليار دولار للحصول على هذا اللقاح
فوق الخط ، لقاح لا يزال قيد التطوير
وعلى الأقل بعد عام واحد يمكن أن يحد
من انتشار  يدفع مشرعو الفيروسات من
أجل أن يتم تغطيتها بواسطة Medicare
مما يجعل اللقاح مجانيًا لواحد من
أكثر الفئات السكانية المعرضة للخطر من كبار السن في
إطار Medicare.
واضح في القانون ، أنا ديفيد
دانييل أبلغ عن
أنه خطير بسبب عدة
أسباب ، أحدها أن نظام الأذى
ليس قويًا بما يكفي لتوفير
أنظمة الدعم التنفسي
المطلوبة لرعاية
المرضى غير المصابين كما رأينا في
يوجد في الصين عدد قليل جدًا من البلدان التي
لديها تلك الأنظمة في
مستشفيات الهند لرعاية عدد كبير من
المرضى ، قد يكون لديهم ذلك لرعاية
بعض المرضى ولكن ليس عددًا كبيرًا من
المرضى إذا كانوا يغرقون مثل
ما نراه في الصين  لذلك من
المهم حقًا إيقاف هذا الفيروس في
مساراته في كل مكان ولكن بشكل خاص
في إفريقيا إذا لم نتمكن من فعل ذلك ، فما
هو سيناريو الأنظمة الصحية التي يجب
أن لا يكون لدينا خيار  يتعين
علينا زيادة قدرتنا على تدريب العديد من الأشخاص
بسرعة على مكافحة العدوى
لتعزيز فحص
منفذ الدخول الخاص بنا في أسرع وقت ممكن
لتتالي التشخيصات في الدولة
بحيث تستمر استراتيجيتنا في
الإملاء السريع والاحتواء السريع
لأن  لا توجد وسيلة
لتحسين أنظمتها بسرعة لتكون قادرة على التعامل
مع تفشي كبير مثل ما
نراه في الصين إذا رأيت
انتقال كومينو ويجب على دول مثل نيجيريا
ودول أفريقية أخرى
إغلاق الحدود إذا بدأنا في البحث عن
انتقال مجتمعي هناك
وهو السيناريو الذي لا نرغب حقًا
في حدوثه لأن ذلك سيعني
ضمان استمرار انتقال العدوى
، ويصبح من الصعب جدًا احتوائه في
تلك المرحلة ، ولا يمكننا التحدث بعد الآن عن
استراتيجية احتواء ننتقل إليها باعتبارها
استراتيجية تخفيف ما  هل نقوم به
للتخفيف من التأثير على المجتمع
الذي سيتطلب أن نبدأ في
إغلاق أماكن التجمعات
الجماهيرية  rches المدارس والمرافق
العامة والتي سيكون لها تأثير اقتصادي شديد
وتأثير اجتماعي على
القارة الحب في زمن
فيروس كورونا والحب كما يقولون
أعمى لماذا أنت
هنا فيروس لكن صديقتي تقول ليست
مشكلة أندريه من روسيا  يرتدي
قناعه رأسًا على عقب
ربما لأن
الناس هنا على الأقل لا يخافون
من السائحين القلائل المتبقين في ميلانو كما
يفعل ميلانيسا دو نادية أجانا نوفا سي إتش
وزوجها لازار من الجبل الأسود ،
لقد رأيت الكثير من الناس لا أحد
يهتم بخورانا
، أعتقد أن هذه دعاية لهذا الفيروس
فقط لأن لديك بالفعل بعض
المشاكل أو أنك من السيخ أو شيء من
هذا القبيل بالنسبة لنا في الجبل الأسود
نحن أشخاص أقوياء وبالنسبة لنا لا شيء
في عصر الأخبار المزيفة هذا ليس
مفاجئًا  أن الكثيرين يتجاهلون
المرض حتى لو كانت حصة الأسد من
الحالات في إيطاليا موجودة هنا في منطقة لومباردي
، فأنا لا أخشى أنها حالة هستيرية أعتقد
أنها هيستيرية إنها مخاوف من الهستيريا  بسبب فيروس
كورونا أدى إلى انتشار وباء
إلغاء الفنادق ، ناشد عضو البرلمان ، جورجيا
مالوني ، من حزب فراتيلي دي إيطاليا ،
عبر Facebook ، الأشخاص
لزيارة إيطاليا
لا تغادروا أجمل محطة سياحية في
الخارج ، ستجدون أمة صحية وسعيدة
فخورة جدًا  أن تكون هنا مع
جميع أصحاب السعادة ، يجب أن نمنحك
انتظارك هنا في إيطاليا ، هؤلاء
الأخوات الاسكتلنديات يتجاهلن كل شيء ، هل أنت قلق
بشأن لا لا لا أنا لأن أختي
قالت إنها مجرد سلالة أكبر من
الأنفلونزا لذلك نحن  لا أشعر بالقلق بأي شكل من الأشكال على
الدهون الشابة في الأشخاص الأصحاء ، لذلك
لا داعي للقلق بشأن
نصح الولايات المتحدة مواطنيها بعدم
السفر إلى أجزاء من إيطاليا المتضررة من
فيروس كورونا وبالطبع نحن في
ميلانو  الذي يتأثر بفيروس كورونا
ونحاول كما قد لا
نجد أي سائح أمريكي هنا في هذا
اليوم لكن قلة من السياح هنا يخشون
على الطيور
لم نكن سي إن إن ميلان